remember when you'd be friends for
dinner at a restaurant or get together
for drinks at a bar it feels like a
distant memory and the pain is most
acute for all the owners and the
employees of the thousands of
establishments that are shut down many
may never open again in Canada the food
service sector is a ninety three billion
dollar industry it employs 1.2 million
workers in normal times 22 million
customers are served across this country
every day when they are allowed to
reopen it won't be the same for
restaurants and bars physical distancing
will limit the number of customers in
the meantime takeout and delivery is the
only option and as Sean O'Shay reports
food delivery apps are taking a big bite
out of the bottom line until March twas
the best year ever our sales went up our
of course went down we were expecting
that hey this is the year that we're
gonna make it 2020 is gonna be our year
that's not the case the new decade
started with great expectations in the
same way for us Arafat took a risk
leaving a secure job in opening this 80
seat restaurant four years ago page one
was named for his fresh start
his new chapter it was and still is an
entrepreneurs dream manual typewriters
provide the atmosphere writing machines
from an earlier era this is a place
where students and creative types would
normally sit and work sometimes linger
for hours sipping coffee and indulging
in sweets then suddenly everything
changed but now it's a different game
there's no customers to attract and we
don't know how are we gonna be able to
maintain enough revenues to support all
the course and keeps up an entire
industry is now asking the same question
from one week to the next
as the Cova 19 pandemic persists
restaurant owners are contemplating how
to stay in business and are wondering
what their business will actually look
like once they're eventually allowed to
reopen for a time at least there will
certainly be fewer seats and tables this
in a business where traditionally
consumers covet a crowd so it
far from ideal you've got a 40 seat
restaurant or bar that sometimes you
want to you know you want to have 50
people in that room in order to create
the experience and so things are going
to be profoundly different and no matter
what happens there's going to be
casualties casualties no one could have
predicted a year ago May 2019 before the
term physical distancing would become
part of our lexicon Toronto Raptors fans
were engrossed in a playoff run one that
captured the imagination of an entire
coupe hungry nation fans never expected
much space of their own as they crowded
in and stood glued to watch a big screen
in bars customers were grateful just to
get in the door in the hope of
witnessing history now over a short but
agonizing few weeks coffee shops
restaurants and bars have closed some
for good others say they'll be back the
rest struggle to remain open
serving takeout and delivery customers
now as just prolongs it's going to be
critical for our survival to be able to
make some money making some money means
relying on delivery apps names like
doordash and skip the dishes you've done
it by ordering from local restaurants in
their time of need
among all names in the food delivery
business the behemoth is uber eats every
time I make an uber delivery I lose
money that's right
Restaurant Group executive Nick DiDonato
says he's actually losing money selling
more food uber eats is now in a position
to dictate almost what restaurants may
survive and may not Hoover eats charges
restaurants the highest commissions in
the industry even though the company
tells consumers that they won't have to
pay to have their food delivered right
now over is not charging a customer who
calls in for a delivery but they are
charging a restaurant 30% commission
that's the price restaurants pay to uber
when a customer places a delivery order
other apps like door - and skip the
dishes charged somewhat less and during
the pandemic competitors have made
concessions door - have looked at the
situation that this is not business as
normal for restaurants and I've actually
cut the rates in half uber has done
absolutely nothing for their restaurant
work the only thing we're doing most
restaurants are doing if anything at all
is takeout and delivery
restaurants prepare to criticize uber
publicly say the company is skimming too
much off the top something that might be
considered improper in normal times but
much worse now but I'm hoping that
people who use these apps begin to
realize how it affects the restaurants
they think they're supporting because
it's not helping the restaurants it's
hurting restaurants right now many
restaurants say for every hundred
dollars spent on a delivery order they
calculate the food cost at thirty or
thirty two dollars the cost of labor to
prepare the food perhaps another thirty
two dollars then ubers cut another
thirty dollars added up and some
restaurants say the formula doesn't
leave much behind for the restaurant
owner the average restaurant in Canada
makes approximately four percent to the
bottom line to make matters worse this
Toronto restaurant for the location in
Vancouver didn't get paid by uber until
seven weeks after the pandemic started
it resorted to Instagram to shame the
company to paying its bill which it
finally did the fact is many restaurants
are afraid to break ties with uber
completely and risk losing the clients
they have who use the app I do need to
get the convenience for those customers
because those are the only customers
left
we asked uber for an interview and
received a statement instead it read in
part Commission's restaurants pay to
overeats for our services is not profit
it goes on Commission's are used to
cover the operating costs of providing
safe reliable services the solution
either needs to be a completely new one
which would potentially involve
restaurants getting together as a group
and potentially organizing their own
system which would include technology
and of course personnel to be the
drivers themselves some restaurant
owners have put uber out of their lives
entirely because it was costing them
just too much that's not sustainable
that global news viewers have met the
owners of Toronto's fat Lam cuisine a--
before now the greek restaurant partners
vera and chris have severed their ties
with ubereats
for good and we haven't been vera and
Chris have redesigned how they serve
takeout and delivery as a result now the
restaurant insists on getting an order a
day in advance to prepare meals mostly
for larger groups who
family-style fare and when the meals are
cooked and ready Chris and Veera deliver
the food themselves at least for now the
result satisfied customers plus they're
keeping more money in the process which
is key for restaurant owners were about
to lose more than half of their capacity
because of health rules he expected that
funeral to kill at least 60% of the
tables from wolf m and the seats that's
why I'm motivated for us our effect will
do whatever he can to eke out survival
in the post pandemic food world and if
that means you want your coffee and
pastry delivered directly that's no
problem but don't use that third party
app message us or text us we are happy
to go and deliver for them or get the
order ready that will save us a lot on
the fees that we have to pay
[Music]